a moment of prayer before waiting into
the freezing Waters of the Rio
Grand the youngest today just 2 months
[Applause]
old this is part of a huge search of
migrants to reach the US Border in
recent days over 4,000 a day in the
Mexican state of quaa alone it's taken
most of them months to get
here they're exhausted but one after the
other they tell us what they've heard
from family and other their migrants
that now is the time to
cross all my friends have crossed they
have all crossed
now we've been waiting four months but
it was very hard to get through
immigration it's better now this is what
lies in store for them hours of waiting
in the cold to be processed by
overwhelmed custom and border patrol
officers on the Texas side of the Border
CBP says the situation is posing a
serious challenge to their
operations
border authorities say the increase in
illegal Crossings is the result of
Smugglers moving large numbers of people
through Mexico but there's always
multiple factors that bring migrants
through Mexico and cause spikes in US
border crossings this year specifically
budget cuts to the immigration Authority
here have meant they stopped detaining
and deporting undocumented migrants in
Mexico meaning many more have been able
to reach the US
border the crisis has led the US to two
of the main crossb cargo Railways
disrupting key supply lines between the
two countries and costing millions in
financial losses the move is partly to
redirect CBP staff to processing centers
and also to dissuade additional migrants
from using the trains to cross
Mexico our biggest concern is the
possibility that several of the
companies affected by this closure will
have to stop
operations as pressure grows on a
sharply divided US Congress to act
thousands more migrants in southern
Mexico are preparing to head north
trying to reach the US before the new
year Julia gallano Al jazer Mexico
City make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer